Cindy do you have any questions for
Emily
no
[Music]
no oh I just finished my salad it's
Howie Mandel here this is Howie Mandel
does stuff
I'm Jacqueline Schultz his daughter how
did you miss that because usually you
say and you are usually you like look at
me and like give me a Q and you didn't
give me a q today I was having a salad
sorry I was having a salad and uh we
have a special guest and and the guest
is Emily how do you pronounce your last
name Emily
and Emily zugai I became a fan of on
tick tock not only me she has millions
of fans and uh she's uh for those that I
think there's probably a few that didn't
see her she's done Ellen and she was a
graphic artist who um seriously this
first time I've seen a background that
your head isn't floating in Emily can
you put on a do you have a filter that
there I wish I could that would be more
fitting wouldn't it yes so um but uh
Emily I saw I didn't know the first time
I saw was a joke and she said she's a
graphic artist and she comes up with new
um logos for various corporate
corporations for what what that's not
the first time I saw you the first time
I saw you was when you were doing stuff
like weird ways to open a banana or
whatever and no one knew that you were
um joking no she wasn't okay and then
she would read some of her comments
afterwards so that's when I saw you
before your logos before the world got
to see the logos that you were designing
that's crazy yeah that's crazy that she
saw you before I did or that she's so
competitive with her own father that she
had to say I saw you first
that was so long ago I didn't hear when
you said wow it was it went out Cindy is
the mic is the mic working
okay no because when you when you yeah
there go tap on it there
Cindy hold it closer to her mouth all
right so uh when did you start when did
you start on tick tock
oh I downloaded it in February of 2021
um right into the mic right into the mic
Cindy lower the mic all right okay go
ahead go ahead
it was February of 2021 and
um I just sort of downloaded it for fun
because I finally
um at that time had graduated from
college and I promised myself
um after college I could download it so
that was sort of what a gift to yourself
what an amazing gift to yourself
if I do good in school
I can download tick tock yeah everyone
was talking about it and how addictive
it was so
I told myself not until after you're
done and uh yeah then I don't know what
happened and here I am do you talk to
yourself a lot Emily
I could talk to myself right
because you said you told yourself
yeah I guess so and what was your first
idea when you went on Tick Tock what did
you want to do with tick tock
um so at first I really just I think I
posted like art videos because I don't
know if you're very familiar with uh my
personal life I don't blame you if you
don't know what time I know nothing I
know nothing about you I just know that
I found you uh really creative and funny
and and wonderful so I don't know
anything about your personal life Cindy
moving to Mike go ahead
um yeah so I actually did graduate with
a degree in college uh for animation and
it was
sort of like when I had discovered tick
tock
I kind of wanted to use it as an outlet
to to I don't know express myself
through ART and whatnot so
um I uploaded a lot of painting videos
some animation work it wasn't anything
like crazy
and then I think I started doing like
Nintendo 64 videos just for no good
reason at all I just kind of wanted to
see what the app could do and
um I actually had a couple videos do
okay on it or you know what was your
first viral video what was your first
yeah my first viral video I would say
was
um okay so this is when I sort of
ventured into like satire
and I made it onto Barstool Sports I lit
a
I lit a match with a lighter and then I
lit a candle and my fiance had filmed it
in a way where it didn't look like I
knew he was recording me so I looked
like the biggest blonde uh like I played
this dumb blonde character I suppose and
you're not actually you're not actually
blonde
well I guess I am blonde but I'd like to
think I'm I'm a little bit smart
um sound keeps going in and out Cindy
you're talking too loud no it's not used
it's Cindy you I don't know if you can
you see Cindy
yes I believe so
yeah Cindy is our sound engineer for
today's uh
broadcast for those that are just
listening and not watching we have Cindy
as our audio engineer
um Cindy Cindy's usually behind the
scenes but since we're doing Zoom today
and you're not actually here Cindy kind
of has to be is there an audio problem
Cindy you could talk into the mic behind
you
no are you a problem
it's not even the mic's not working
Cindy holding try it again try it again
no I like it no audio problem okay okay
there you go okay there we go so
continue
oh
what were we talking about I'm so sorry
I was just a little distracted by the by
what um outfit
the tie-dye shorts I know well during
covid everybody got into tie-dye and
stuff and making bread and Cindy's no
different than any one of us looks good
on yeah but but some of the biggest
companies came to you and asked you to
redesign your logos right like seriously
asked them and they just yeah what was
it was crazy go ahead oh no sorry
um
we had well so it all had begun as just
sort of like a joke and I'd chosen
random companies
um and I didn't know it would be
anything bigger than than just like my
average video which I I I can't
speak on how many views I got at that
point but it wasn't anything that really
I I don't think surpassed like a million
um but then yeah it started to catch on
and we had companies in the comments
asking for Logos and then soon we were
able to do like Partnerships and brand
deals and I could actually make money
off of it which I didn't realize I could
do it first so
um yeah so they're actually paying you
to do redo their logo yeah yeah it's not
all of them but um a lot of them after
the initial like first couple of videos
yeah what if what are there are there
any brands that got upset or offended at
first when they didn't like your first
videos when you started doing it and you
would pick a brand and then you would do
it and would are there any that reached
out to you that were like please don't
do that or take it down or got upset
I don't think so I was I did I put
Disney in one and I was like I wonder if
they're going to send me like a cease
and desist letter and that didn't even
happen so I felt very lucky because is
it Forward of me to say can you design
the Howie Mandel does stuff uh logo with
it the problem is it doesn't include my
daughter Jacqueline Schultz and she's
been oh yeah we need all the elements
yeah
and Cindy of course so the podcast is
Howie Mandel does stuff her name is
Jacqueline Schultz she's always been mad
at me from the beginning that her name
has not been included
um and I think that we have to throw a
special uh you know
shout out to our everybody backstage
that produces this but Cindy Cindy has
been on audio right from the beginning
and just has done a stellar job it's a
podcast and audio is
prominent right Cindy
that's right I feel like we could have
your face in everybody else's face or
yours and Jaclyn's then and then
don't even tell us how it works you just
you just do your thing you do your thing
I have a vision you do oh my God I
cannot wait for this I cannot wait to
see this that is I'm so honored because
I saw you did everything from Disney to
Ellen to uh Tick Tock to tick tock
themselves right did they did they reach
out to you or you just did that
um so I I just done and just just to
clear the air Disney didn't ask me I
just did there's an
um hoped for a response but I didn't get
one that's fine so I love your I love it
you're less monotone than you are on
your post but I love that monotony just
makes me
it just makes me laugh it's just it just
I I really gotta say that very little as
a comedian you know I always go that's
funny that's funny that's funny you
really made me laugh out loud I looked
forward each and every day to watch your
tick tocks and everything are there
still people in the comments that don't
know you're joking
yes absolutely I mean it depends on the
type of video but um if it's like a
how-to video a lot of people I will do
edit I'll see in my notifications and um
they'll just call me out or yeah they
seem like what are you doing Cindy do
you have any questions for Emily
not at the moment when you do just wave
okay
all right
um I'm really excited I wanted to talk
to you I wanted to meet you I wanted to
see the real Emily and most of all I
wanted to get a logo
and I wanted to post it and we need help
with our merch too
Cindy do you have a question
no
So Silent oh
I just
just spending time
foreign
thank you
so much
Cindy turned the music louder